I'm looking for a new video game to play
can you give me a recommendation
overwatch I play overwatch yeah it
squeals um overwatch is amazing
Oh which is amazing yeah generally
Blizzard is great stuff um well this
hearthstone I haven't tried that one yet
yeah I know people love it that's what
my kids play the most is hot stone
alright also from blizzard
I will check that out tonight alright
well thank you very much for the time
and I gotta get going
cool do you play in people's eyes over
which I'm on we try the new districts I
have tried the new day sexed it's okay
but like you look the best game I played
recently it's not a super new game is
the last of us oh is it really Mac Uppal
years ago sure I loved it okay last of
us yeah you like that - is it really
good yep yeah I've heard good things
about Uncharted I was just like really
the last of a story time great video I
mean honestly I think that that's really
neglected I mean that's the the Christus
of a hood of the latest Deus Ex is the
story storytelling is kind of lame like
where is the one the prior day of sex
and the original the original Deus Ex
was the storytelling was amazing and if
anybody's played have you you played the
original Deus Ex that was killer as
games have become more like the
replacement for the NFL I think the
storytelling just gets generally
neglected yes like especially striking
to play one that was like absolutely
cinematic yeah story time and some of
the oldest games that the graphics and
sound were terrible so they had to rely
on storytelling yeah like the old Mario
games had incredible story yeah
you